- [Voiceover] Alright everyone.
We've gotten to one of
my all-time favorite
multi-variable calculus
topics, divergence.
In the next few videos I'm gonna describe
what it is mathematically
and how you compute it
and all of that but
here I just want to give
a very visual understanding of what it is
that it's trying to represent.
So I've got a picture in
front of us, a vector field.
I've said before that a pretty neat way
to understand vector
fields is to think of them
as representing a fluid flow.
What I mean by that is you can think of
every single point in space as a particle,
maybe an air particle or a water particle.
Something to that effect.
Since what a vector field does
is it associates each point in space
with some kind of vector
and remember I mean, whenever
we represent vector fields,
we only show a small subset
of all of those vectors,
but in principle you should be thinking of
every one of those infinitely
many points in space
being associated with
one of these vectors.
The fact that they're
kind of smoothly changing
as you traverse across space
,means that showing this
very small finite subsample
of those infinitely many vectors
still gives a pretty good
feel for what's going on.
So if we have these fluid particles
and you have a vector
assigned to each one,
kind of a natural thought
you might have is to say
what would happen if you let
things progress over time
where at any given instant
the velocity of one of
these particles is given by
that vector connected to it.
As it moves it will be
touching a different vector.
So it's velocity might turn.
It might go in a different direction.
For each one it will kind
of traverse some path
as determined by the vectors
that it's touching as it goes
and when you think of all
of them doing this at once,
it will feel like a certain fluid flow.
For this you don't
actually have to imagine.
I went ahead and put together
an animation for you.
So we'll put some water molecules or dots
to represent a small sample
of the water molecules
throughout space here and then
I'm just gonna let it play
where each one moves along the
vector that it's closest to.
I'll just let it play forward here
where each one is flowing along the vector
that's touching the point
where it is in that moment.
So for example, if we were to go back
and maybe focus our
attention on just one vector
like this guy, one particle, excuse me,
he's attached to this
vector so he'll be moving
in that direction but just for an instant
because after he moves a little
he'll be attached to a different vector.
So if you kind of let it play
and follow that particular dot
after a little bit you'll
find him elsewhere.
I think this is the one, right.
Now he's gonna be moving along this vector
or whatever one is really attached to him.
Thinking about all of the
particles all at once doing this
gives a sort of global
view of the vector field.
If you're studying math,
you might start to ask
some natural questions about
the nature of that fluid flow.
For example, you might
wonder if you were to just
look in a certain region
and count the number
of water molecules that
are inside that region,
does that count of yours change
as you play this animation,
as you let this flow over time?
In this particular example you can look
and it doesn't look
like the count changes.
Certainly not that much.
It's not increasing over
time or decreasing over time
In a little bit, if I
gave you the function
that determines this vector field,
you will be able to tell
me why it's the case
that the number of
molecules in that region
doesn't tend to change
but if you were to look
at another example,
like a guy that looks like this
and if I were to say I want you to focus
on what happens around the origin,
in that little region around the origin,
you can probably predict
how once I start playing it,
once I put some water molecules in there
and let them flow along the
vectors that they flow along,
the density inside that region
around the origin decreases.
So we put a whole bunch of vectors there
and I'll just play it for a quick instant.
Just kind of let it jump for an instant.
One thing that characterizes
this field around the origin
is that decrease in density.
What you might say if you
wanted to be suggestive
of the operation that I'm leading to here
is that the water
molecules tend to diverge
away from the origin.
So the kind of divergence
of the vector field
near that origin is positive.
You'll see what I mean
mathematically by that
in the next couple videos,
but if we were to flip
over these vectors, right,
if we were to flip them around,
now if I were to ask about the density
in that same region around the origin,
we can probably see how
it's gonna increase.
When I play that fluid flow
over just a short spurt of time,
the density in the region increases.
So these don't diverge away, they converge
towards the origin.
That fact actually has some
mathematical significance
for the function representing
this vector field
around that point.
Even if the vector field
doesn't represent fluid flow,
if it represents a magnetic field
or an electric field or things like that,
there's a certain meaning to this idea
of diverging away from a point
or converging to a point.
Another way that people
sometimes think about this,
if you look at that same kind of
outward-flowing vector field
as rather than thinking
of a decrease in density,
imagining that the fluid
would have to constantly
be repopulated around that point.
So you're really thinking of
the origin as a source of fluid
and if I had animated this better,
a whole bunch of other points
should be sources of fluid
so that the density doesn't
decrease everywhere,
but the idea is that points
of positive divergence
where things are diverging away
would have to have a source of that fluid
in order to kind of
keep things sustaining.
Conversely, if you were to look
at that kind of inward flow
or what you might call
negative divergence example
and you were to play it but
it were to go continuously,
you'd have to think of
that center point as a sink
where all the fluid kind
of just sort of flows away.
That's actually a technical term.
People will say the
vector field has a sink
at such and such point or
the electromagnetic field
has a sink at such and such point
and that often has a certain significance.
If we go back to that
original example here
where there is no change
in fluid density, right,
what you might notice,
this feels a lot more like
actual water than the other ones
because there is no
change in density there.
If you can find a way to
mathematically describe
that lack of a change in density,
it's a pretty good way
to model water flow.
Again, even if it's not water flow
but it's something like
the electromagnetic field,
there's often a significance to this
no changing in density idea.
So with that I think
I've jabbered on enough
about the visuals of it
and in the next video
I'll tell you what
divergence is mathematically,
how you compute it, go
through a couple examples,
things like that.
See you next video.